willkommen zur ein spiel wie wahrheit
oder pflicht ohne die wahrheit watcher
zahlen um zuzusehen player spielen um
geld und ruhm zu gewinnen bist du roger
oder player oder player
wir sind für den kinofilm nerf unterwegs
der am 8 das bin ich
die challenger sticker von passiert denn
die war echt schlecht kann aber nicht so
krank wie unsere zellen oliver muss ich
klar das ist jetzt schon die zweite und
wir wünschen euch ganz viel als katze
auf sommerfesten katzen kostüm das auch
passt beide in das schwarze auto
ok ja bloß nicht annehmen muss
red
[Musik]
franken
mango
[Musik]
macht ihr keine ahnung ich weiß erst gar
nicht
wir sollen 200 meter geradeaus gehen
ok 199 zwei monaten ins auto also
annehmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
warte mal ich muss ich dann machen
[Musik]
ich war gar nicht hier mit ja
was aufs dach
ich bin aufgeregt
natürlich war
als vorher
bereits ladung fahren ja alles klar
ok los gehts vanessa los geht's
[Musik]
ok fast 50 alles klar
ja und ich soll dabei ein eis essen
[Musik]
red
ein
rang
[Applaus]
auf jeden fall mega mega fox gemacht
alles bestanden alle diese kurven die
man so krass ich eigentlich
und wenn ihr uns jetzt helfen wollte ist
finale zu kommen da müsst ihr unbedingt
bei unserem hashtag bittl mitmachen und
zwar müsst ihr den hashtag battery kelly
mal wandel so oft benutzen wie es nur
geht damit wir ins finale kommen jahre
war nämlich unbedingt ins finale und ihr
jetzt auch challenges bestreiten wollt
dann könnt ihr eine app downloaden alle
infos dazu sind in der infobox machte
auf jeden fall mit dann könnt ihr diese
coole changes machen wir gerade hat
gefehlt
willkommen auf der end karte hier findet
ihr unsere letzte challenge als ist
kelly gejagt haben
das ist auf kellys kanal hier findet ihr
von krankhafter ab dem 31 8 die nächste
challenge aber unbedingt vorbei ja ich
hoffe du hast spaß ich hoffe ihr habt
spaß und wir haben jetzt noch ein
bisschen spaß
bei
[Musik]